autres invités politiques ce matin c'est
marc fesneau bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous au ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
et de la participation citoyenne et vous
êtes également candidat aux régionales
dans votre région sauval de loi on va
bien sûr longuement parlé on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale qui représentait
justement par la presse de votre région
bonjour christophe gendry merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous directeur de la
nouvelle république dans le département
du loir et cher cher un marc fesneau
on va parler avec vous bien sûr dans
quelques instants de dossiers régionaux
christophe et de la campagne des
régionales mais d'abord les actualités
marc chesneau et gérald darmanin qui
présente donc ce matin en conseil des
ministres un projet de loi pour
améliorer la prévention des actes
terroristes renforcement du suivi des
terroristes des outils de renseignement
ce texte il sera présenté quant au
parlement il sera présenté début juin à
l'assemblée nationale
parce que nous avons des délais qui sont
contraints en fait c'est là c'est une
nouvelle mouture du texte dit loi sylt
pour un objectif de ce qui est très bref
et très court de de lecture définitive
de vote définitif avant la fin du mois
de juillet et donc on démarre à
l'assemblée nationale au début du mois
de juin c'est un texte qui est important
parce qu'il permet de prolonger un
certain nombre de dispositifs on revient
devant le parlement
conformément à ce que la loi prévoit il
ya des clauses de revoyure et c'est bien
normal et par ailleurs ça permet
d'affiner un certain nombre de choses au
fond tirant parti de l'expérience parce
que c'est ça qui est important dans ce
dans ce genre de chose c'est des sujets
très sérieux on a malheureusement eu à
en connaître la semaine dernière et donc
il faut en permanence adapter nos outils
à la menace terroriste dont on voit
qu'elle peut évoluer parfois vers ce
qu'on appelle des loups solitaires c'est
à dire des individus dans la
radicalisation se détecte très
difficilement et souvent très tard
malheureusement et justement ça pose
plusieurs questions d'abord vous le
disais un set un texte qui est prévue
depuis plusieurs semaines mais qui se
télescopent malheureusement avec
l'actualité et l'acte terroriste qui a
été commis vendredi à rambouillet est ce
que du coup le gouvernement à modifier
ce texte en conséquence
non je pense que les éléments qui sont
prévus dans ce texte le suivi des
personnes radicaliser le suivi à la
sortie d'une mesure de
de prison de ces mêmes perçu
personnalité je pense que là on a un
arsenal
simplement ça appelle les affaires de
terrorisme s'appelle de la collision
nationale me semble-t-il parce que tout
le monde est confronté à ça et d'une
grande vigilance de tous les instants je
me permettrai de quand même de saluer le
travail des services de renseignement on
a aussi mis des moyens beaucoup plus
importants c'est plusieurs milliers
d'agents qui sont dédiés à ces tâches de
renseignement de surveillance du
territoire pour essayer de lutter pied à
pied papa contre le terrorisme il faut
le faire avec beaucoup d'humilité parce
que c'est des choses qui sont très
difficiles à faire mais en tout cas on
renforcent encore l'arsenal législatif
d'autant que vous le disais on a affaire
à des loups solitaires on l'a vu à
rambouillet 1 c'était un homme seul qui
n'était pas repéré par les services de
renseignement est ce que le législateur
l'exécutif sont impuissantes à sa
subtile de personnes non parce que on ne
le dit pas assez tous les actes de
terroristes ou de terrorisme plutôt
qu'ils sont évitées chaque semaine
chaque mois ce qui mène tel ou tel
depuis le début du quinquennat dit les
grandes opérations les grandes
opérations terroristes et des gens qu'on
surveille en permanence au fond de ce
point de vue là la prévention la
surveillance la surveillance du
territoire
la surveillance de ce qui se passe sur
les réseaux sociaux permet de 2
comment dirais-je de parer à ce genre
d'acte mais malheureusement on l'a
encore vu vendredi c'est une ville en
vigilance de tous les instants et donc
en amont a besoin de se doter de ces
outils là vous l'avez entendu de la part
notamment de la droite le débat qui
revient sur le lien entre immigration et
terrorisme est-ce que pour vous il ya un
lien mais non je trouve que faire ce
lien là c'est faire un amalgame qui me
paraît extrêmement faux et extrêmement
dangereux la seule chose qu'il y à faire
c'est de vérifier que les personnes qui
viennent sur notre territoire il y en a
certains qui sont venus de théâtre
d'opération y compris deux théâtres
d'opération qui sont soumis à des lois
du terrorisme si je peux dire
soit bien identifiée pour qu'on puisse
les renvoyer chez eux le cas échéant et
qu'on puisse en tout cas discerner ce
qui viennent pour des raisons
migratoires on à la question de la 10,2
des flux migratoires à maîtriser on
s'est dotée elle a aussi d'outils
puissants depuis le début de ce
quinquennat ça veut pas dire qu'on est
au bout du chemin
on voit bien que ces décès des choses
qui sont complexes sur le contrôle aux
frontières notamment sur le contrôle aux
frontières mais on voit bien que faire
un lien entre immigration et terrorisme
c'est être dans le faux au fond et c'est
faire des amalgames qui me paraissent
très dangereux après l'important c'est
de détecter ces individus qui ne sont
pas ils ne sont pas très nombreux mais
qui sont très dangereux et qu'il faut il
qu'il faut surveiller à toute force vous
valez de la politique migratoire en
décembre dernier était prévu au
parlement un débat sur la politique
migratoire il a été annulée à cause de
la crise à la place ils en débat sur la
stratégie vaccinale et il n'a jamais été
remis à l'ordre du jour ce débat est ce
que le gouvernement a peur d'un tel
débat
je crois pas qu'on ait peur d'aborder
ces questions alors sur les sujets
parfois on nous dit qu'on en fait trop
parfois on nous dit qu'on en parle trop
et là vous me dites que au fond on
aurait craint tout inquiet sur ce sujet
non c'est une question de calendrier
parlementaire
ça veut dire qu'il va être bien
évidemment un moment ou un autre dans le
calendrier parlementaire on remettra à
l'ordre du jour ce débat mais c'est vrai
comme vous l'avez dit que la crise
sanitaire qui est l'objet de toutes nos
préoccupations est le premier élément
de l'action du gouvernement à la fois
dans la gestion de la crise elle-même
mais aussi dans la gestion des
conséquences de la crise des
conséquences économiques et sociales la
gestion de la formation et des
établissements scolaires mais le temps
viendra où on reparlera de ces questions
par le b quand est ce que ça sera avant
l'été pas de date à vous donner à ce
stade c'est pas prêt d'environ la dg pas
de panique si j'ai pas de date à vous
prêt à vous donner à ce stade à la voix
il ya une offensive sécuritaire de la
part d' emmanuel macron il ya ce texte
qui présentait ce matin est ce que
quelque part le gouvernement cherche à
corriger l'image d'une certaine
faiblesse sur le régalien
moi j'accepte qu'on dise toute la vérité
c'est que pendant des années on a parlé
des affaires de terrorisme
la réorganisation des services de
sécurité intérieure et des services de
lutte contre le terrorisme
la baisse des effectifs la baisse des
effectifs de police de manière continue
depuis des années avant que nous
n'arrivions ce n'est pas de l'eau à
mettre au débit du quinquennat qui ce
qui est en cours
c'est à mettre au débit de tous ceux qui
avant ne se sont pas préoccupés de ces
questions là c'est plus deep mille
policiers et gendarmes qui vont être
qu'ils vont être recrutés sur le
quinquennat on tient la promesse qu'ils
étaient au rendez-vous de la de la
présidentielle de 2017 alors faut sans
doute encore déployé des moyens
supplémentaires mais venir nous dire que
nous n'aurions pas pris la mesure des
choses le président de la république a
pu faire un point d'étape sur un certain
nombre de dispositions on ne découvre
pas ces questions de sécurité est loin
de les découvrir en plus on agit et donc
c'est par les effectifs de police il ya
pas un commissariat de france qui ne
verra pas ses effectifs de police dans
la durée du quinquennat augmenté je
pense que c'est ça c'est s'est
concrètement comment répond c'est par
des moyens sur le terrain qui permettent
de lutter contre les actes de
délinquance ou les actes de terrorisme
l'autre texte qui est présenté ce matin
en conseil des ministres le texte sur la
sortie de la crise sanitaire ils
seraient examinés pour le coup par les
députés et les sénateurs
dès le retour des vacances
parlementaires je crois qu'il est
inscrit le 18 mai au sénat l'assemblée
ça sera quand du coup un peu avant la
semaine d'avant la semaine du 10 mai est
ce que ça veut dire qu'on sortira de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire tel qu'on le
connaît dès le 1er juin
alors c'est un texte qui vise à la fois
mettre en place des dispositifs de
sortie comme on a connu au printemps
dernier est par ailleurs de pouvoir
disposer encore d'outils qui permettent
le cas échéant quand voir surgir un
épisode épidémique dans tel ou tel
secteur dans telle ou telle région je
vous rappelle ce qui s'était passé à
marseille où ce qui avait pu se passer
dans le département de la mayenne
il faut qu'on se dote aussi même si
c'est provisoire d'outils qui permettent
quand même de faire attention à des
phénomènes épidémiques qui nous qui nous
échapperait dans tel ou tel territoire
donc c'est un sortie type celle que nous
avons connue le printemps dernier
aucun régime transitoire est un régime
en train mais transitoire de sortie de
l'état d'urgence a quand même la volonté
bas il y aura des étapes et des
ponctuations c'est des parlementaires
qui le diront il ya un certain nombre de
choses qui seront sur des durées de
l'ordre de quelques mois évidemment la
volonté du gouvernement c'est de sortir
de ce régime qui est un régime
particulier puisque c'est un régime
d'état d'urgence
on est quand même reconnaissons leur
encore dans une situation d'urgence qui
nécessite de disposer d'outils qui nous
permettent de faire face à cette crise
l'autre sujet d'actualité c'est la
sphère sarah halimi qui pose la question
de l'irresponsabilité pénale le garde
des sceaux a annoncé un projet de loi
fin mai sauf que le sénat avait déjà
inscrit son propre texte à l'ordre du
jour le 25 mai pourquoi vous n'avez pas
repris le texte du sénat et inversement
le sénat il à inscrire est assez
récemment à l'ordre du jour mais comme
vous le savez communistes des relations
avec le parlement je fais en sorte que
les textes et ses deux cheminées 100 kg
et de compétition qui me paraissent
malsaine je les fais d'ailleurs et nous
l'avons fait sur le texte
la proposition loi billon dit billon sur
les violences sexuelles faites aux
mineurs je trouve qu'on a fait un
travail intelligent qui n'était pas un
travail de compétition je pense que ces
sujets oui très bien mais on va on va on
va on va s'organiser de faire le le
sénat est tout à fait dans son droit et
dans sa légitimité le gouvernement au
dessus aussi et nous sommes pas tout à
fait sans doute sur les mêmes
dispositions législatives l'important
c'est qu'on trouve au fond une réponse
un sujet qui est très très difficile
c'est le sujet de à partir de quel
moment juste que quelqu'un était
responsable et à partir de quel moment
au fond on laisse les victimes sans
réponse pénale et et c'est bien ça la
difficulté alors l'alternance n'est pas
question de remettre en cause en soit la
question des responsabilités
il ya un certain nombre de cas où on a
pu provoquer d'une certaine façon par le
fait d'absorber déçu ce temps des
substances illicites
on a pu provoquer ça une forme
d'irresponsabilité mental
il faut qu'on y travaille c'est des
sujets la cour de cassation a dit le
droit
et manifestement le droit n'est pas
satisfaisant parce que moi je comprends
très légitimement l'émotion qui
suscitait par le fait au fond on se
contente de dire la personne n'était pas
responsable et est donc vous n'aurez pas
le droit même un procès qu'ils puissent
débattre de ce qui s'est passé et de ce
qui s'est passé en termes pénales donc
moi je crois que le gouvernement
travaille on travaillera avec le sénat
ils ont un texte
on verra le gouvernement travaille
soutiendraient le texte du sénat on
avoue permettrait au gouvernement
d'avoir ses propres
comment dirais-je son propre champ
d'investigation on peut trouver des
compromis on la trouvait sur la ppl
billon on l'a trouvée sur de bien
d'autres textes avec le sénat et il me
semble que tout ça est ce qu'il ya de
plus normal on est sur des sujets
suffisamment sensible pour pas qu'on en
fasse une querelle politicienne et une
chorale politique entre le sénat où
l'assemblée nationale et le gouvernement
je suis sûr qu'on trouvera les voies et
moyens pour trouver un chemin
un dernier mot sur le plan de relance
puisque la france transmet ce matin sa
feuille de route à bruxelles
objectif toucher les 40 milliards du
fonds européen on a vu hier bruno le
maire olivier dussopt devant les
parlementaires est ce que le parlement
il sera consulté sur syfy de routes
assurant un débat là-dessus il est le
que le parlement est toujours associé à
la feuille de route parce que c'est une
feuille de route aussi budgétaire qui
est donné au parlement est par nature et
par construction le parlement est
associée l'assemblée nationale sénat
s'est il y aura un débat spécifique
social il ya double des airs débat
spécifique alors soit c'est en
commission soit 7 en séance publique
il ya un débat spécifique sur ce qu'on
appelle la stabilité le ligne de
stabilité budgétaire et donc évidemment
et il est normal puisque ça déjà fait d
un relèvent du champ budgétaire que le
parlement puisse être informée puisse
débattre lui-même des perspectives
budgétaires que donne que donne la
nation française et l'union européenne
on va passer à la crise sanitaire
c'était votre premier déplacement de
campagne en bleu mais salutaire marc
chesneau et on va en parler avec
christophe gendry oui s'entremêlent de
loi est actuellement une des régions les
plus touchées
l'épidémie de 8,19 les services
animation les hôpitaux sont maintenant
au delà la saturation alors qu'est ce
que cette crise 10 de notre système de
santé tel rôle si vous la région
peut-elle jouer pour participer à ces
rénovations
alors elle y puise alors plusieurs
choses est d'abord bonjour elle dit
plusieurs choses de de la situation du
pays
d'abord sans doute que nous n'étions pas
collectivement préparer à une faire face
à une crise sanitaire comme celle là
mais en même temps que le système
sanitaire a pu s'adapter
le printemps dernier et comme ils
s'adaptent là vous avez raison de
souligner que les hôpitaux sont en sur
serre tueur saturation en région centre
val de loire
je pense que pour le coup là il ya une
grande part qui relève de l'organisation
de l'état ce que j'aurai salue aussi
c'est qu'on a pu mettre en place
comment dirais-je d'une forme de
fluidité entre le privé et le public
qu'on a pu mettre en place une forme de
nouvelles formes d'organisation entre la
médecine dite de ville et la médecine
hospitalière et que tout ça fait un tour
on le voit d'ailleurs aussi dans la
politique vaccinale vont permettre et
quand même au passage de saluer j'étais
effectivement ça a été le choix de mon
premier déplacement parce qu'on est en
crise sanitaire c'est une crise qui est
très difficile pour les soignants pour
ceux évidemment qu'ils sont malades de
saluer toutes celles et ceux qui
travaillent alors après il ya un
deuxième sujet sans doute en région
centre val de loire qui est très
spécifique c'est le sujet médical et
démographie médicale sur lequel la
région peut peut agir ce que je constate
parce qu'il faut aussi parler du bilan
c'est que depuis dix ans la situation
s'est plus dégradée qu'ailleurs en
région centre val de loire ce que je
constate c'est que en région centre val
de loire
il ya que 13% des votes des citoyens de
cette région qui ont accès plus de
quatre fois un médecin par an
quand en france la moyenne est à 30 de
plus de 30% 33% de tête
alors il suffit pas de dire je vais
faire je vais
dire je vais salariés des médecins parce
qu'au fond les grandes annonces sont une
chose mais concrètement sur le
territoire il ya un certain nombre de
gens qui n'ont pas de médecin référent
il ya des réponses qui peuvent exister
les maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires
mais la maison de santé des récits
pluridisciplinaire nasa les financés par
la région et l'état d'ailleurs au
passage elle n'a un sens que si à
l'intérieur on arrive à y trouver des
médecins
donc il faut faire feu de tout bois si
je peux dire je dis quand même au
passage que c'est tout ça c'est qu'on
est héritier d'une situation qui est
celle d'ap delà d'avoir restreint le
numerus clausus ont l'art est ouvert
cola mais vous voyez bien que le numerus
clausus il produira ses effets que dans
7 8 10 ans et donc il ya un travail dans
l'intervalle affaires de réorganisation
les comités les communautés
territoriales de santé sont des outils
qui se permettent de lier les
professionnels avec les collectivités et
d'essayer de travailler et donc il faut
travailler sur l'ensemble des sujets je
donne un autre une autre voix me
semble-t-il que j'ai vécu dans ma propre
commune c'est la question de l'accès aux
stages les internes
quand vous avez des intérêts qui vont
auprès de praticiens de ville médecins
libéraux ils découvrent le métier il
découvre le territoire et ils ont envie
de s'y installer parce que
l'installation des médecins s'est pas
seulement la formation des médecins
l'installation des médecins c'est la
capacité d'attractivité du territoire
les garder une fois qu'ils sont formés
parce qu'une fois qu'ils sont formés ils
peuvent s'installer partout en france et
donc le sujet n'est pas seulement que
nous ayons beaucoup plus de médecins qui
soient formées pour la médecine générale
mais c'est que nous fassions en sorte
qu'ils aient envie de rester et y
installer il suffit pas de dire j'ai
fait une maison et ça suffit le
président la région sortant a indiqué
qu'il allait depuis plusieurs mois même
voire années a dit qu'il allait salariés
des médecins ça se compte sur les doigts
d'une de demain peut-être le nombre de
médecins qui sont salariés donc les
grandes annonçant une chose le concret
est une chose plus plus importante en
tout cas pour ceux qui ont envie de se
soigner bien une des conséquences de
cette crise c'est la fermeture
de commerce est également deux
établissements touristiques
comment expliquer aujourd'hui tout
risque ce qui était très forte dans la
région sans bandeau noir
comment expliquer que les châteaux les
jardins les embrouilles l espace et où
la distanciation physique puis je les ai
respectées comment expliquer que ces six
châteaux soit toujours fermée
aujourd'hui pour une raison simple c'est
que ce qu'on a appris du virus en
particulier des variants qui sont
beaucoup plus contaminant c'est que il
ya la fois les lier aux causes contaminé
puis les moments d'interaction plus vous
multipliez les moments d'interaction et
c'est vrai que vous avez moins de
chances d'attraper chances entre
guillemets de mal chance d'attraper le
virus dans un lieu extérieur que dans un
lieux intérieurs
sauf que quand vous mettez en mouvement
des tas de gens c'est bien les principes
de la des règles qui ont été établies
depuis quelques semaines puis vous
mettez en interaction les gens plus vous
leur faites prendre des risques plus ou
multiplier les chemins les interactions
entre les citoyens plus vous avez des
risques d'où les mesures qui sont qui
sont effectués mais pour essayer de
répondre plus avant à votre question
évidemment l'objectif c'est que ces deux
là soient les premiers ouverts vous avez
raison de le dire et vous connaissez
très bien cette région c'est une région
où les lieux touristiques les jardins
les châteaux sont des lieux ouf on peut
avoir le sentiment d'être plus en
sécurité donc dès lors qu'on va libérer
la question des distances à partir
desquels on peut on peut se déplacer dès
lors que la vaccination continue à
progresser j'étais aussi dans un centre
de vaccination olivier la semaine
prochaine on peut espérer que les choses
sont importantes
d'ailleurs nous avons vécu dans notre
région dans mon département du
loir-et-cher dans notre département du
loir-et-cher année thé ou au fond on a
vu un afflux très significatif de
touristes venant de notre région mais
aussi venant des autres régions parce
que on voit bien que c'est une forme de
tourisme qui - tourisme de masse et qui
correspond aux besoins du moment et aux
contraintes du moment et donc on peut
espérer qu'avec toutes ces mesures on
puisse avoir un été qui soit plus
conforme à ce qu'on en est en
ce qu'on souhaite on va parler
d'agriculture christophe oui alors marc
fesneau a été maire de marchenoir
étudiants comme une personne que vous
connaissez sa sensibilité aux questions
agricoles en justement la réforme de la
pac provoquant une très vive inquiétude
dans les campagnes en ce moment quelle
est votre position à ce sujet qu'est ce
que vous avez à dire aux agriculteurs
on sait qu'ils peuvent internationale
libérer des normes ou vous leur imposez
alors deux choses sur la politique
agricole commune sans rentrer trop dans
la technique
il ya deux piliers ya le premier pilier
qui est le pilier plutôt économique puis
le deuxième pilier qui est plutôt le
plier développement rural sur le pilier
économique la principale inquiétude je
crois qu'on est en train d'élever il ya
des règles de ce qu'on appelle
l'écoconditionnalité les échos régime
qui qui doivent permettre aux
agriculteurs d'assumer des transitions
qui leur sont demandés qui sont des
transitions extrêmement difficile mais
en même temps il faut que le maximum
d'agriculteurs puisse y avoir accès pour
qu'ils puissent avoir accès et
puissances engagées dans cette
transition écologique ça c'est un
premier point de vigilance
nous discutons beaucoup avec julien de
normandie sur ce sujet je pense que sur
ces sujets là on va pouvoir avancer
positivement deuxième point le de ce
qu'on appelle 2e pilier le volet
développement rural sur ce volet
développement rural structurellement
cette région est moins dotées que les
autres la répartition des enveloppes
peut-être qui a été fait depuis des
années a été une répartition qui s'est
fait en défaveur de la région centre val
de loire alors il appartient aussi au
gouvernement mais il appartient aussi au
président de la région en ce moment en
place de discuter avec ses homologues
des autres régions pour expliquer que
notre région en particulier ces zones
intermédiaires
je pense au sud du département du loir
et cher et je pense au sud de notre
région pour faire un axe nord-sud
séparés par la loire on a besoin
d'outils de développement rural qui
permettent de maintenir des activités je
pense par exemple à des activités
d'élevage mais aussi par exemple des
activités de polyculture donc tout
l'enjeu d'un président de région et
c'est celui là que je veux être c'est de
faire en sorte que on défende les
intérêts de la région et qu'on ne soit
pas les bras ballants le long du chemin
à dire ah c'est pas de notre faute c'est
les autres qui ont plus de moyens je
pense qu'il faut se battre au niveau
national c'est ce que je fais pour ma
part comme ministre mais aussi comme
élus de ce territoire de faire en sorte
que cette région puissent se voir doter
de moyens qui lui permettent d'assurer
les transitions par esor les mesures
agri environnementales et puis troisième
chose la concurrence nous sommes dans
une concurrence mondiale et une
concurrence européenne mais faudrait pas
non plus qu'on organise
laurence intra régional si à toutes ces
normes qui sont parfois difficiles et le
gouvernement essaie de ne pas en
rajouter on rajoute des normes
régionales qui font qu'au fond mais
déboulé supplémentaire au pied des
agriculteurs région centre val de loire
par rapport à leurs voisins à leurs
homologues du bassin parisien des pays
de loire alors là on fait défaut et on
voit bien que les équilibres politiques
qui ont été tenus dans cette région il
vise à chaque fois la seule réponse
qu'on fait c'est ont normalisé
on fait de la contrainte supplémentaire
et on dit ça va bien aller comme ça sauf
qu'on crée une distorsion de concurrence
entre les territoires de la région et
moi je pense qu'il faut accompagner les
transitions il faut pas les accompagner
par la contrainte je connais bien le
monde agricole vous avez raison c'est un
monde qui est prêt à bouger mais pas pas
de la façon dont les choses sont faites
est ce que la région a plus avancé
depuis des années avec 7 mai deux
méthodes là la réponse est non
christophe m'en a parlé rares domaines
importants pour la région c'est
l'économie oui tout à fait et au nom de
domaine économique je te vole notre
région est très impliqué logistique mais
aussi la sous traitance automobile ou la
nautique alors est-ce que ça peut se
conjuguer
si on le long terme avec les enjeux
environnementaux et dans le même
registre est votre position sur les
subventions de la région apporter aux
aéroports de châteauroux et tours
si j'étais lui la résidence est ce que
vous maintiendrez ces subventions ah oui
parce que là pour le coup faut pas
tergiverser parce que je vois bien que
l'exécutif en place tergiverse parce
qu'il a des contingences avec les
écologistes l'aéronautique et
l'automobile c'est une chance pour
l'économie de notre région
nous sommes la deuxième ou troisième
région de sous traitance aéronautique la
part de l'aéronautique dans le
réchauffement climatique
c'est moins de 3% par ailleurs
l'aviation est en train de faire sa
mutation y compris avec les moteurs à
hydrogène les moteurs électriques et
déjà la consommation énergétique parce
que c'est l'intérêt des avionneurs
d'ailleurs et de réduire sa consommation
et donc cette espèce de modèles qu'on
essaie de nous vendre qui est un modèle
anti voitures anti avions alors je sais
qu'on n'a même plus le droit de rêver
d'avion -un et bientôt nous expliquera
qu on a même plus droit d'avoir son
permis de conduire c'est une question de
rêve mais c'est plus qu'une question de
rêve c'est une question de développement
économique qu'est ce qu'on dit aux
salariés qu il n'y a plus d'avenir à la
voiture on a à blois décide très
prestigieux en termes automobiles qui
ont essayé qui essayent à toute force d'
accélérer les mutations en travaillant
par exemple sur l'hydrogène dans une
région comme les nôtres on a besoin de
ces emplois on a besoin de la voiture
ça veut pas dire qu'on est pas pour la
transition de la voiture qu'on doit pas
faire un choix vers l'électrique qu'on
doit pas faire un choix
l'hydrogène est donc on a absolument
besoin de soutenir ces industries
aéronautique et ses industries
automobiles quant à tours et châteauroux
il faut fermement défendre ces deux
plateformes aéroportuaires qui ont dès
qu'ils ont des vocations différentes la
plate forme de château a plutôt une
vocation de maintenance aéronautique et
la plate forme de tour est plutôt sur le
voyage mais là aussi faut avoir une
politique qui soit claire il y en a un
peu assez de d'une politique qui se fait
à la corbeille des accords par partisans
et on a besoin d'une politique qui soit
claire et déterminée transition
écologique et en même temps une capacité
économique et capacités de développement
pour cette région parce que c'est les
deux peuvent se mener de pair j'en suis
absolument certain quand j'étais
vice-président du syndicat d'énergie du
loir et cher on a développé les bornes
électriques sur le département du loir
et cher il faut sans doute encore
accéléré ces processus donc je ne me
ferai pas enfermer dans des débuts les
gens qui nous donnent des leçons et qui
ont fait on fait beaucoup moins beaucoup
parlé on fait assez peu et pour terminer
christophe on va parler de la campagne
électorale à proprement parler oui alors
lors de ces régionales pour aller
chercher une lutte au second tour il
faudra des alliances a dans tous les
camps d'ailleurs est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à travailler dans le futur avec la
liste est pris à 12h08
il faut le rappeler laquelle vous étiez
associés il ya six ans est-ce qu'à
l'époque vous étiez d'ailleurs les
policiers le guillou question leur est
cher wasquehal ou est ce qu'une entente
est possible avec françois bonneau le
président sortant quels sont vos axes de
travail
alors d'abord je vois les listes qui
fleurissent che mais fleury chez mes
concurrents je vois beaucoup des listes
des tickets talents multiples il est
parti il ya des listes avec huit ou dix
parties on essaie de faire des quotas
ils font un troisième manifestement il
faut que le parti communiste soit
troisième sur la liste de monsieur bono
dont il ya une forme de quotas moi je ne
constituerait pas une liste parti m je
fais partie de la majorité
présidentielle je défends le
gouvernement j'ai pas besoin de le
répéter 25 fois par jour mais c'est une
certitude et une réalité j'assume ce que
je suis deuxième élément je suis du
modem et je les assume depuis des années
comme vous le savez j'ai fait d'ailleurs
dans des situations de risque
j'entendais à votre antenne monsieur
bono qui donnait des leçons et qui
disait c'est une voie de secours pour un
ministre
ils cherchent à toute force à rester en
place alors que ça 25 ans ça fait 25 ans
qui sont en situation de changer les la
région et que manifestement il n'y ont
pas réussi
moi je prends mon risque j'ai décidé
d'essayer de mettre mes compétences mon
expertise nationale et locale au service
de la région c'est bien ça qui comptait
deux mois je ne me préoccupe pas de ces
questions d'alliances de second tour et
d'équilibrage voit bien qu un certain
nombre de gens font des listes avec
cette préoccupation ma préoccupation
c'est de sortir en tête et ma
préoccupation c'est d'offrir aux
habitants une alternative à ce débat qui
que certains voudraient construire et de
se faire en sorte qu'une nouvelle
majorité sortent de la région et donc
c'est les électeurs qui décideront de ce
qui se passe le soir du premier tour et
plus nous placerons au plus on sera en
situation de pouvoir gagner et dernière
question n'est pas cité ses assemblées
nationales ce qui laisse selon jour
mesure le champ voulu l'échiquier cette
région bah le rassemblement national
dans cette région et je rappelle que la
dernière fois il était au dessus de 30
autant me souvienne premier au deuxième
tour il est en mesure évidemment de
bouleverser l'échiquier il n'est pas en
mesure en revanche de répondre aux
problèmes quotidiens des citoyens de la
région centre val de loire et moi je je
comprends absolument les colères je vois
ce qui se sentent délaissés les
territoires qui ont eu l'impression
d'être totalement abandonnés depuis des
années mais les qu'il n'y a pas de
solution dans le solutions concrètes à
ce qu'offre le front national c'est m
c'est un vote qui exprime une colère la
réponse qu'il faudra qu'on apporte nous
c'est une réponse concrète pour que les
gens n'aient plus cette colère et vit
différemment sur nos territoires a
rapidement marc fesneau puisque on lit
ce matin dans le figaro vous pour faire
campagne vous avez déployé des faits
nous mobile qu'est ce que c'est c'est
pas moi qui n'ai de qui est donné sur
non mais je vois le surnom qui est donné
la volonté c'est voyez bien qu'on est
dans une campagne qui fait qu'on ne peut
pas faire de rassemblements publics et
je compte bien me conformer à cette
règle mais je pense que du coup il faut
aller à la rencontre des citoyens et la
volonté que nous avons au travers de six
véhicules qui tourneront dans chacun des
départements dans quelques jours de
faire ensemble d'aller à la rencontre
dans les villes et les villages les
citoyens pour leur exposer nos
programmes qui leur phase nous fassent
part de leurs récriminations de leurs
propositions de leur réaction parce
qu'on va leur proposer au fond s'il faut
qu'on aille à eux puisque c'est plus
difficile qui viennent à nous et donc
c'est une façon nouvelle moderne et puis
c'est une façon de montrer que c'est
comme pour les services c'est comme des
tas de choses il faut aller au coeur des
territoires il faut pas demander
simplement aux gens de se déplacer vers
nous merci beaucoup merci rufino d'avoir
été notre invité merci christophe
gembrie d'avoir été avec lyon pour cette
interview
[Musique]